Drawing poppies between the crosses row on row,...
...reciting "In Flanders Fields" while visualizing a time so long ago.
Years before reason, rationalization, and political bias sets in,...
...these children here at Ottawa's Mindware Academy...
...create their own ideas of Remembrance Day:...
...sadness, but also happiness, for the people that survived;...
...a time to remember all the people who gave their lives...
...to make a world a better place today;...
...remembering soldiers that passed away in World War II or World War I.
He goes on to say he also thinks about soldiers...
...who are currently at war.
They kind of fight for us...
...so the other team doesn't get to our place and take over our school.
These children all wear poppies...
...and more importantly, know why they're wearing them:...
...because it represents the people that passed away...
...and the people that fought and survived.
You have to remember about the soldiers in your heart.
That's the reason why.
Kyle here made his own poppy.
Right now, it's made of Lego, that's my favorite.
I have tons of Lego at my house,...
...so I have good designs in my head.
Do you think it'll ever catch on...
...and everyone will be walking around with Lego poppies?
Well, I'm not sure because I don't have a lot of Lego pieces...
...left of red and black pieces,...
...so I have to see about that one.
Like many schools across the region, Mindware Academy....
...will offer Remembrance Day ceremony and moment of silence later this morning.
They did a whole bunch of things for us,...
...so it's not that hard to take one minute out of your time...
...to bow your heads and think of the people who sacrificed their lives for us.
In Ottawa, Laura Lowe, A Morning.